[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole et
d'outre-mer la france est d'un donnant
son histoire votre choix sera d'une
grande importance
je crois en la france en son talent en
son génie à sa capacité de surmonter les
épreuves durant ces quatre dernières
années on nous avons dû affronter des
crises d'une violence inouïe
elle a souffert mais l'un d'eux est la
tenue parce que nous avons agi
l'immobilisme nous aurait conduit au
désastre pour les cinq années qui
viennent ce sont les valeurs du travail
de l'effort et du mérite qui nous
permettront d'être plus fort et de
reprendre la maîtrise de notre liste
les
nous voulons la formation à chaque âge
de la vie pour lutter contre le chômage
nous devons agir pour que tout jeune qui
ne poursuit pas des études est un droit
à la formation professionnelle et à
l'alternance agir pour que tous chômeurs
qui ne trouvent pas de travail
suivent une formation et se voit offrir
un emploi correspondant à cette
formation
nous devons croire dans l'autorité parce
que l'autorité protège et que ce sont
les plus exposés qui en ont le plus
besoin
nous voulons une école où l'autorité du
maître et du savoir et reconnaît pas ce
que nous ne pouvons éduquer nos enfants
sans un minimum d'autorité sans un
minimum d'exigences parce que le laxisme
ne rend pas service aux enfants
[Musique]
nous devons agir pour que plus jamais un
enfant ne sortent de l'école primaire
sans maîtriser la lecture et l'écriture
nous voulons la responsabilité qui est
la condition et la liberté de chacun
parce qu'il n'y a pas de droits sans
devoirs parce que les droits et les
devoirs
c'est la morale de la république nous
devons croire la solidarité et refuser
la système celui qui travaille doit
toujours gagner davantage que celui qui
ne travaille pas nous devons agir pour
que la république exige la connaissance
du français et le respect de nos valeurs
avant de pouvoir entrer sur le
territoire agir en divisant par deux le
nombre d'étrangers
nous accueillerons dans les cinq années
qui viennent agir pour obliger l'europe
a changé en exigeant qu'elle défende ses
frontières en luttant contre les
délocalisations en imposant la
réciprocité dans les échanges
commerciaux
en refusant d'ouvrir nos marchés tant
que les autres n'auront pas fait et en
réservant nos marchés publics aux
entreprises qui produisent en europe
agir comme nous l'avons fait pour sauver
notre système de retraite
agir pour réduire nos dépenses et nos
déficits agir en adoptant une règle
d'équilibré obligatoire pour nos comptes
publics pour les cinq années qui
viennent
mes chers compatriotes c'est en restant
fidèles à nos valeurs
c'est en agissant que nous construirons
une france forte capable de protéger les
français et de leur rendre la maîtrise
de leur destin
[Musique]
la france est grande c'est cette chose
que je veux construire avec vous
j'ai besoin de vous
[Musique]